we're asked to simplify log base 3 of
27x and frankly this is already quite
simple but i'm assuming they want us to
use some logarithm properties and
manipulate this in some way maybe to
actually make it a little bit more
complicated but let's give our best shot
at it so the logarithm property that
jumps out at me because this right over
here we're saying what power do we have
to raise 3 3 2 to get 27 x 27 x is the
same thing as 27 times x and so the
logarithm property we it seems like they
want us to use is log
base let me write it log base b
of
of a times c i'll write it this way log
base b of a times c this is equal to the
logarithm base b of a plus the logarithm
base b of c and this comes straight out
of the exponent properties that if you
have two exponents two with the same
base you can add the exponents so let me
make that a little bit clearer to you
and this part is a little confusing the
important part for this example is that
you know how to apply this but it's even
better if you know the intuition so
let's say that log let's say that log
base b of a times c is equal to x so
this thing right over here evaluates to
x
let's say that this thing right over
here evaluates to y so log
base b of a
is equal to y
and let's say that
this thing over here evaluates to z
so log
base b of c
is equal to z
now what we know is this thing right
over here this thing right over here or
this thing right over here tells us
tells us that b
to the x power
is equal to a times c
now this right over here is telling us
that b to the y power is equal to a
b to the y power is equal to a and this
over here is telling us that b to the z
power is equal to c
let me do that in that same green so i'm
just writing the same truth i'm writing
as an exponential function or an
exponential equation instead of a
logarithmic equation so b to the z power
is equal to c these are this is the same
statement
this is the same statement or they're
the same truth set in a different way
and this is the same truth set in a
different way well if we know that if we
know that a is equal to this is equal to
b to the y we can and c
and c
is equal to b z
then we can write
b to the x power
is equal to
b to the y power
b to the y power that's what a is we
know that already
times
b to the z power
times b to the z power and we know from
our exponent properties we know from our
exponent properties that if we take b to
the y times b to the z this is the same
thing as b
to the under the neutral color b to the
y plus z power this comes straight out
of our exponent properties and so if b
to the y plus z power is the same thing
as b to the x power that tells us that x
must be equal to
y plus z
x must be equal to y plus z if this is
confusing to you don't worry about it
too much the important thing or at least
the first important thing is that you
know how to apply it and then you can
think about this a little bit more and
you can even try it out with some
numbers you just have to realize that
logarithms are really just exponents and
i know when people first tell me that i
was like what does that mean but when
you evaluate a logarithm
you're getting an exponent that you
would have to raise b2 to get to a times
c but let's just apply this property
right over here so if we apply it to
this one we know that log
base 3 of 27 times x i'll write it that
way is equal to
log base 3 of 27
plus
log base 3
log base 3 of x
and then this right over here we can
evaluate this tells us what power do i
have to raise 3 to to get to 27 you
could view it as this way 3 to the
question mark is equal to 27
well 3 to the third power is equal to 27
3 times 3 is 9 times 3 is 27 so this
right over here evaluates to 3. so if we
were to simplify or i guess i wouldn't
even call it simplifying it i would just
call it expanding it out or using this
property because we now have two terms
where we started off with one term
actually if we started with this i'd say
that this is the more simple version of
it but when we rewrite it this first
term becomes three
so this first term becomes three and
then we're left with plus
log base 3 of x so this is just an
alternate way of writing this original
statement
log base 3 of
27 x so once again not clear that this
is simpler than this right over here
it's just another way of writing it
using using logarithm properties